um i don't know and then you guys um i'm
curious too because i was when i was
just talking with seth hendricks and
what i appreciate about
generation now is you guys truly like
every artist really is getting it out
the mud like it's not like
there's not a [ __ ] magic switch to
hit like people really think jack
harlow's a new artist
but if you've been tapped in like he's
been doing his thing with y'all for like
three years
and you know and the same thing with
seti like
i think that like the work is what kind
of you know
i feel like you guys are very conscious
of the work
like and making sure like hey look it's
not as much because you
you guys could probably sign whoever you
know what i'm saying
but you guys definitely take the long
way like someone like jack harlow
who this it's not like he had a buzzing
single and you guys grabbed him up
right and then just you know threw some
gasoline on the fire
you guys built the [ __ ] fire from
from the jump
um so talk about that like just your
guys is like
talent process like what is it you got
to see an artist to want to bring them
over to generation now
and the same thing can be said about
oozy too by the way what do you see an
artist
conviction uh inspired artists a lot of
artists come to you they're not inspired
you know what i mean they just don't
have a vision uh
they just wanna rap and i you know i
personally just
you know me and john working so long
we've known it you know see we've known
when we seen people with conviction
the people that used to be at you know
532 glen iris was like his house that
was the
the hub for all this you know mm-hmm was
that that's where gangster girls were
and we still just watched so many people
like we watched david banner come in the
white van and be like yo i'm not leaving
until i get against the girls
you know paul wall came down here and we
used to do houston
latex new york parties and he's like
rapping you know what i'm saying
certain people you just the eyes just
tell it all for them you know
and i think that's what happened a lot
of artists like jack came in that was
the eyes you know who's he's
even seti like a lot of the artists you
just know
you know you start feeling like oh they
gonna do whatever it takes
to get there you know what i mean yeah i
think there's they all have that in
common like that's one thing i could say
about their instinct
definitely the three of them you know
and when it comes to
generation now on the label when i think
about uzi jack and seti like
their passion and they're like i'm
i'm gonna get there like all three of
them have
have that instinctively and like to a
thousandth degree
yeah i i saw something on twitter it's
like it you can't
want it more than your management or
your label
because then you're wasting everyone's
time and i feel like a lot of artists
like you'll meet that are fire
and you know [ __ ] just doesn't work out
and it's and it's really
like they're lacking in that they're
doing music as they can not because they
like they want to you know absolutely
absolutely